بين التوقيتين في لبنان ضاعت مواعيد
واختلطت اخرى وامتزجت المشاعر بين الغضب
والسخريه من ازمه عقارب ساعه تحدث العالم
بغرابتها
ناجي واحد من الشباب اللبناني الغاضب من
سلطه افتعال الازمات التي لا تؤثر الا على
شعبها
انا الصراحه اثر علي كثير تشكر الكتير
يعني مؤذي اذا بدك يعني انا كنت هلا
المفروض عند حكيم من ساعه انا هلا فليت من
الشغل راح علي الموعد صار لي اسبوعين بس
بركض ورا هالموعد ليزبطوا ولهلا لزبط من
ورا هالتوقيت رحل موعد الحكيب
على اي توقيت انت سؤال يرافق اللبنانيين
في خطواتهم اليوميه كما حصل في بدايه ازمه
الدولار وانتشار مواقع والتطبيقات تنشر
اسعار الصرف المختلفه بات للتوقيت في
لبنان موقع ايضا قديش الساعه هو احد هذه
المواقع وعندما ندخل نرى هذين التوقيتين
انترناشونال تايم من بيروت اي التوقيت
العالمي في بيروت و بي ام تي اي بال نقاط
تايم وفي البدايه هناك اشاره وبطريقه
فكاهيه الى ان هذا التوقيت هو حسب سوق
التوقيت بدل السوق السوداء
حالات الضياع انسحبت على المؤسسات
والمدارس والمصارف بين من بقي على التوقيت
الشتوي ومن غيره الى الصيفي على انعم
مدرسه تيتو الجديد يعني الصيفه الشرعي
ولاده
الشتوي فبكره بالعاده انا ولادي من البيت
فبكره انا راح فلن يعني ما ضايعه مش
عارفين كيف بدنا نمشي
استغلت ازمه التوقيت لتصفيه الحسابات
السياسيه ونبشت قبور الطائفيه ما دفع
برئيس حكومه تصريف الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي
وبعد اجتماع الحكومه الى اعلان العوده الى
التوقيت الصيفي ليلى الاربعاء الخميس بعد
معالجه الامور التقنيه ناهد يوسف العربيه
بيروت